si vous voulez ne rien afficher sur
l'écran d'accueil de votre smartphone de
Samsung c'est désormais possible je vous
montre comment il faut faire et bien
vous venez vous rentrez dans votre
smartphone directement vous faites un
appui long et vous allez dans fond
d'écran et style vous cliquez juste ici
sur votre écran d'accueil et là vous
cliquez sur votre horloge sur votre
horloge vous avez une option qui
s'appelle aucune horloge vous venez me
désactiver l'horloge en gros ensuite
vous pouvez venir virer les différentes
petites icônes que vous avez là vous
allez sur aucune et moi je me suis juste
gardé un petit message en bas Galaxy S23
ultra de Monsieur greu vous cliquez sur
Terminer et là vous venez dessus et vous
avez un smartphone qui est clair neuf
rien d'écrit c'est beau c'est limpide ça
me plaît bien et ça c'est chouette
d'ailleurs dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que ça pourrait vous
plaire oui non quoi comment est-ce que
vous connaissez cette astuce marquez de
moi dans les commentaires